Carol Baskin
I'm Carol Baskin was the name Joseph
Maldonado passage mean anything to you
he is a psychopath who wishes me dead
we've been in an ongoing dispute with
Joe
I'm sorry I understand this must be very
hard for you
oh no sorry I'm allergic to cats
I really feel like I was put on this
Earth to rescue cats welcome to the best
exotic animal show in these
this is who we've been after
documented animal abuser Joe Exotic
we're coming for you
I didn't even know if you had a husband
almost 12 years
I come from a home
that didn't feel like a sanctuary when
there are no more animals in cages then
there will be no more need for us to
rescue them
shower rooms are you looking for
something that will stop a hit man in
his cracks
we're gonna make a family in this part
no one can say a damn thing about it
Here's To The Unwanted animals
it ain't just about the cats spoiler
alert
so how many people are going to see this
little documentary years I'm gonna blow
some [ __ ] up he shot me
three times he shot you technically it
was a blow up doll of me we're ready to
roll
this is a show I can sell this America
is gonna love you
I will never stop
if you've got any dirt on this woman I
want to hear about it he has no idea
what I've been through in my life is
this awesome or ridiculous individually
we are a whimpered
but together we are a roar
stop cat people are a little weird
[Laughter]